welcome
and thanks for joining i'm glad you're
all here my name is dino kieza
i work for google on the apogee team my
role is to help customers
understand and use apogee to solve their
business problems
today we're going to talk about service
mesh and api management
and how t-mobile adopted both of these
to improve their capability to deliver
innovation
securely and at scale
this isn't news enterprises are evolving
their monolithic applications
into microservices architectures
modeling a system
as a set of interconnected microservices
helps organizations to build and
maintain
complex distributed systems more easily
the theory is
small grain services can be
independently developed versioned
deployed scaled and updated
meaning a more flexible agile approach
as the system grows
it's an attractive idea and service mesh
infrastructure
has been built to help manage these sets
of intercooperating services
lightweight proxies like linker d or
envoy
management tools built on top of these
these allow the services to find each
other
communicate securely and scale
elastically
but no enterprise no matter how modern
consists
only of systems built on microservices
that's one category in a portfolio which
includes
custom monoliths and third-party sas
systems
now service is only useful if developers
can find it
get the credentials required to connect
to it and then build and run an
application
using those credentials for good hygiene
we've got to manage and measure all that
activity
this is where api management comes in
it helps you manage the apis that are
shared outside of each domain
and remember sharing could be across
domains within a company
now i want to talk a little bit about
api management and its enabling of
modernization that transition from
monoliths to microservices
one capability of an api management
system is to intelligently route
requests from clients to back-end
systems
when you introduce a new system you can
use the api management layer
to migrate those requests this is a
really common use case among our
customers
the routing can be dependent on any
factor and can be dynamic
client applications can be completely
unaware that this is happening
and that facilitates a phased migration
with control
apogee is api management and it's
cross-cloud
allowing you to manage apis across your
entire portfolio
your own data center public clouds
third-party sas
wherever the service is run with that
now i'd like to invite my friend terry
to talk about t-mobile's modernization
journey
and how they used api management and
service mesh as complementary pieces
of their foundation terry
thank you dino hi my name is tarawan
i work on api management and service
mesh in
api center for enablement team at
t-mobile i'm glad to be here
first i want to talk about our api first
journey
to be honest it's been quite a journey
for us at t-mobile
we introduced aputy six years ago to
jump-start
our api program back then we had very
few
micro-services or even restful services
majority of the services were soap based
delivered by middleware platforms or
custom java applications
we used apigee gateway mainly to
transform
the soap payloads into json to make them
easier for the ui application to consume
four years ago t-mobile embarked on the
digital transformation journey
and made the api first strategy as one
of his main drivers
we started to break down monolithic
into macro services we had tremendous
growth
not only in number of services but also
in business
agility it used to take months to make
changes now many apps are releasing
daily
it's so rosy right yes but we definitely
experienced the growing pain
we still had multiple platforms
languages
and libraries security was still
difficult to implement
and observability and delivery were
inconsistent
that's why we started to look into ucl
service mesh
we successfully deployed our pilot
services
into production last year now we're
planning to roll out in big waves
in both our public and private clouds
since our team started two years ago
we've been working on building
to bootstrap api development in every
phase
of the lifecycle we have swagger linter
in design phase to make sure the api
design standards are followed
in development phase we provide teams
with apigee proxy
and ucl match generators in build
and deployment phase we give domain
teams the cicd pipelines with compliance
checks
these tools allow development teams to
deploy their services
into apigee and service mesh
in a secure and receiving manner in
every step
in the api development lifecycle the
events are logged
metadata is collected and they are
searchable through our api explorer tool
where both api consumers and providers
can find relative information about
their services quickly
this improves our mean time to recovery
when issues occur
we're very proud of these tools that
enable us at t-mobile
running our api program at scale
what really motivated us to look into
istio service match
with the shift left in security strategy
a couple years ago
we wanted to enforce strong token
authentication
for all the apis with proper logging and
monitoring
for any security violations we created
token libraries for java
and made it available to the development
teams
it worked well in some degree we had
hundreds of services adopted the library
however there's still thousands of apis
left
and many programming languages to cover
that got us
into istio which provides security
and granular matrix we're looking for
and more
out of the box the features such as
circuit breakers and security handling
connection timeout and retry and
telemetries
are often handled by the development
team in the code
depends on programming languages and
libraries and project timelines
sometimes
these features were implemented in
different ways
and managed by different tools they were
inconsistent
big overhead for teams to manage and
operate
with the service mesh these features are
offered
at platform level using standard
policies
the overhead for these advanced features
shifts from developers
to the service mesh it helps development
team deliver product features
and deliver them faster and more
securely
service match and api management solve
two different problems
together it transforms your backend
services
into apis that are consumable by
internal
and external applications the service
mesh gives more details
to service clients about the topology of
the architecture
the resilience mechanisms they should
implement
and granular telemetry they should
collect
and security flows they participate
all these implementation details are
provided
to application but envoy cycle process
with api management we're trying to
solve
the problem of when we wish to expose
existing apis for others to consume how
do we track
who uses these apis and enforce policies
about
who's allowed to use them and establish
security flows
to authenticate authorized permissible
use
and build a catalog of services that can
be used
at the design time to promote api usage
at t-mobile our services are built in
different sizes and forms
they are deployed in various platforms
in on-prem cloud
or public cloud api management layer
allows us to provide consistent
endpoints
to the consumers and laser foundation
for effective
governance api gateway and service mesh
architecture
is the paved road at t-mobile for api
development next i'm going to demo
our fpga proxy generator and ucl match
generator tools
they enable developers to deliver
services faster
with a strong security by default
in this session i'm going to demo a
couple generator tools
in our tool suite ucl config gen
and apd proxygen the purpose of these
generators is to write
developers quickly get onto the platform
and take advantage of the platform
features right away
without spending too much time to learn
it
so that they can focus more on
developing
their domain specific features these
generate readers
bundle a default set of features often
required
to make the service more secure and
follow
the best practice set forth by the
company definitely developers can always
add their custom policies and
configurations
that meet their specific requirement
later
out of the box the default should
already provide
70 to 80 percent of the features
okay let's get into it
uh let's look at the uco mesh
jam first we always follow the api
first approach so the mesh config
generator is actually a micro service
it's restful service
it will generate the sperm boot app
the ucl home chart and a default csd
pipeline
and then we use a home chart to deploy
the configurations into ucl clusters
let's look at um
more details about
the eco config gen so this is the
request
object for the generator service
so you specify the user information this
is used for auditing
team purposes and you specify type of
applications
sprint board or some other types and
where do you want to store the generated
artifacts if you want to generate the
micro service based on the swagger by
default you can
specify the swagger information and
the java based class and some other
informations
and for ucl right so you need to specify
where
where's your cluster where do you want
to deploy
these apps to however you can change
or add other configurations later
so one of the features is required is
the security
jwd token validations this is required
by any services at any layer to
reinforce the zero trust
so these are the configurations and
luckily
i used to provide this feature by
default you just need to configure it
let me run this
service
okay it will take a few seconds
but you will see a new folder should be
created in the repository
now it's started generating and the
issue configuration
is stored at a common folder
and these are the features um
we bundled together as a default set the
authentications
and um you know the service entry
and circuit breakers and a default
canary release pattern
and hpa and some other routings
i want to get specifically into the
authentication
configuration so we enable mtos
and jw token validations
so uh this this is to make the service
more secure
and you don't need to implement the
libraries at the code level
so um
we also generate a
default cd pipeline which allows you to
you know deploy your config
configurations into the cluster more
easily
so the the pipeline will build the java
app
and push the container image into
the registry and do the static code scan
and run the default set of a unit test
and finally deploy it into the cluster
and you can customize this all you want
and uh the default should
work for most of the teams
okay so i generated one uh yesterday
to save time because um you know the
the whole process running through the
cicd pipeline will take
about seven minutes um
now you can see everything is running
green it's deployed into the uco
cluster so which is running
up here now i can launch
a test to verify the features
so if i don't have the token
the better token and i should get 401
yes it's unauthorized right so
if i include valid better token
now it's getting through however my
service
since it's not implemented what through
501
right so the other one i want to test
is that i exclude the house
check path right so without the token
it should work just fine so let me
verify that yes i don't have any
better tokens and i'm getting the valid
response
okay so this is how easy
it is to um you know adopt the the uco
um you know the features
and you can quickly deploy your
microservice
into the cluster secondly
i want to demo
the apigee proxygen
just from a swagger file and you can
specify
the apigee proxy names and some other
routing rules and will generate
a default set of policies
and then you can deploy into any uh rpg
environment
whether or not it's sas or on prime
you know it doesn't matter so with this
approach
we achieved end-to-end
you know connectivity and security
so let me show
the generator a little bit just to save
time
i already um built uh
this um uh configuration already
and it's everything is based on this
swagger
and give the swagger will have the
default values for you
you specify where do you want to uh
store the generated project
and how to route to your targets and
what the project information is for
tracking as well
and you know finally
so you can submit
will generate a
rpg uh csct pipeline for you
so over here it generates the proxy
endpoint to generate the target
endpoints
and then there is a pipeline
generated and then we'll do
uh you know quite a few compliance
checks
and the uh authentication authorization
checks and
threat protection checks and you know
loggings
we definitely need uh and also the coda
and uh the spec arrest for
uh traffic policies and and then you can
just
deploy to any environment uh you want
so you can customize it to add more
as you wish
so
i want to show you what what the
the policies um looks like uh
when they deploy into the rpg
environment
so you can see that um by default will
use
the shared flow for many of these pos
policies and there's a
default set of policies for pre-flow
and another default set of policies for
post client post flow and there's
logging policies
um you know in in the post client flow
so um you know without you knowing
anything about
apigee you're able to just expose
your service um on the apigee
and exposed to other teams to consume
so now let's look at
um you know the end-to-end testing
so i do have this um you know service
up here this is configured um
you know exposed through the apigee and
connect
to the service i just deployed
in the ucl environment so without
the token
i should get 401 so this is from rpg
right so not allowing to pass to the
back end
at all this is security protection if i
do
have um
[Music]
the joe token i'm
past passing through apigee layer and
getting into
uh the ucl service mesh and i'm getting
the
501 not implemented which is the correct
response
so if i give the wrong
token i'm getting a more generic
message so this is um
you know when you expose to apigee
and you're getting more unified
error messages for all these services
you know exposed through rpg
so the third feature i want to
demo is our api
explorer tool
so we collect all the informations on
every step of the process including the
generator
including the deployment you know from
the api explorer you can
get all those informations um
you know from swagger's specification to
where it deployed and
who's consuming and who owns this and
you know what's the revision history
so one of the things i do want to show
is the telemetry right
so um you know this is the ipg proxy
i deployed today by me
and i want to see the matrix
since i deployed yesterday i did some
testings today so it shows
all the details about this service
and shows how it performs and what error
it can get
um you know this is um
the end of my demo which shows you how
to
use the generators to deploy your
service
into istio and expose through rpg
and you're getting a default set of the
features
and and also the telemetries
you're getting thank you very much
thanks for that terry it's super
interesting to learn about t-mobile's
journey towards greater flexibility
and agility in their systems which
brings me to the last thing i'd like to
mention
apogee hybrid when customers use the
apogee sas
gateway which runs in the google cloud
the connection from the client to the
gateway to the upstream service
can span multiple public networks
with apogee hybrid you can run apogee
gateways co-located with your workloads
this flexibility means you can avoid
crossing network boundaries
while still enjoying that same great
apogee capability
so consider that if you need that
capability
finally i'd like to summarize a couple
things we learned today
api management complements microservices
architectures
second t-mobile's journey combines api
management and service mesh
with processes and tooling to produce a
platform on which t-mobile developers
build the future and finally apogee
hybrid provides
even more flexibility for those who need
it
both terry and i thank you for watching
this session to continue the
conversation i've set up some
expert one-on-one sessions over the next
couple of weeks
we will be answering your questions in
the q a
section for this session also thanks
again